regarding healthcare I think not only
should be state-sponsored but also the
pharmaceutical company have a duty to
provide medicine where it's needed in
country that can't afford to buy those
medicine because anyway they don't
consider the market and there is need
for instance HIV treatment and places
like Nepal or whatever where I live to
follow the treatment will be two three
months of wages every month so it's
impossible so that's why there's a duty
from the manufacturer companies also to
provide a developer to pry that can be
afforded so that's a human duty and that
would be also extraordinary to express
the sense of global responsibility